hey what's up my name is samuel leeds i
am a property investor and in this video
i'm going to be answering your questions
around property investment so please
comment all of your questions below
and i'm going to do my very best to
answer your
specific niggling property investment
questions
also don't forget to smash the like
button subscribe to the video so that
when i answer your question next week
you don't miss the answer
also as i answer questions from last
week if you have a
offshoot of a question so as i'm
answering someone if you think but what
about this
just comment it below in form of a
question and i'll endeavor to answer as
many questions as i can
so let's see what we had last week so uh
michael
davis quite a long question but i'll
read it quickly
just going to property i started
watching your videos
um i bought two bites left properties
and i've saved 25
deposit on each on a repayment mortgage
so i'm only making around 200 pounds
on each property i wish i'd maybe got
them on interest only
now due to cash flow advantages that you
mentioned i'm thinking of going for a
brr
next after watching your videos i
actually live
in a converted mercedes sprinter van
on an acre of land i bought for five
grand
fair play all right um while renting out
the houses
so i'm completely debt free i've got
another 25 000 pounds lined up for the
next properties i'm very excited
you sound like an interesting character
question shall i use that
and get bridging finance and then do up
the house and refinance it
rather than my current strategy all the
crash courses are booked and sold
out so i'm gutted keep up the good work
i hope my question gets answered michael
davis here is me answering your question
so firstly it sounds like you got a real
strange setup there like living
in a in a mercedes van
on a piece of land that you bought i
mean fair enough if
if if you enjoy it then great it sounds
really strange
but but cool in terms of the your
strategy yeah your strategy at the
moment isn't really working too well
because you're having to save up
i don't know how you're saving up all
that money i guess probably because you
live on a piece of land that you bought
for five grand
but you're saving up all your money and
you invest in it
but you have to keep working really hard
to keep saving the money so you'd be
better to work smart by doing exactly
what you said
which is by putting into a property
adding value and pulling it out
just make sure that when you do that
it's about finding the right type of
property
so you want to find a property that's
maybe unmortgageable
if a property's got no kitchen and
bathroom guess what it's unmortgageable
and then you buy it cash and bridging
make it mortgageable and push the value
up and then refinance it i think it's a
great strategy let me know how you get
on and hopefully we'll meet in person
and in terms of the crash courses being
sold out
um look there's always i'm running so
many events
i'm on tour at the moment um running the
property millionaire intensive and
people are like oh it's sold out but
they're talking about the one near their
house is sold out i would say just drive
get to wherever you got to get to make
it happen i'll leave a link in the
description
good job all right um ian says narrow
sleep
ian says no will sorry will
i'm 23 years old what's the best way to
invest 50 000 pounds
single let's hmo or is 50 grand enough
to invest into brr
it depends on what you want to achieve
well if you want to achieve
cash flow fast cash flow i'd probably
put that into rent to rent
if you want to achieve a little bit of
both decent cash flow but you just want
to invest it and you want
to go up in value maybe hmos is good buy
a hmo in an area where they're about to
bring
article 4 in and then rent the rooms out
and then you'll have automatic
grandfather rights
um brr very good for wealth building
so if you're wanting to recycle your
cash and grow a portfolio then brl's
real good
it depends on what you want to achieve
it really does but um
50 grand if you put that into something
like rent to rent
and it's gonna go obviously really far
you could grab a massive portfolio but
you don't own anything apart from the
business that's making the money
um which some people want some people
like i just want to leave my job
if you invest 50 grand into a brr deal
and you hate your job it's going to be a
long time before you've got out of your
job
so it just depends on what your goal is
let's meet man come down
come down to some training i'll leave a
link in the description saeed says
when approaching land owners what do you
think the best
process is after they contact you from
receiving your direct to vendor letter
to achieve a quick agreement or sale so
saeed
when i'm sending out landlords if
someone calls me up and i've sent them a
letter about their land
i will then go and meet them at the site
because you know a land deal can be very
very lucrative
it's off market direct to vendor if
they're saying you know what i'm open to
selling
then there's potentially good money to
be made there
and the land deals that i go out to
generally speaking a minimum six figure
profit
so assuming that it's not too far from
home i would go and meet them
ask them what their situation is listen
to them then go away do some due
diligence and put forward an offer
space man i'm looking at brr
with money i've gathered how would i
best set up a company to do this
is there any better way than others to
build and organize a company for this
strategy
um spaceman i wouldn't worry too much
about the company set up
i think that's more of an accountant's
job
rather than you having to spend lots of
time thinking about it your job is to
find
the best deals possible and then are you
gonna do it through a company
are you gonna do it through your
personal name are you gonna set up
an llp i mean i would speak to an
accountant and say what is gonna be most
tax efficient because it really does
depend on your situation
who's there i'm currently a student is
there any way i can get on the property
ladder while in uni to get a head start
absolutely yes you can in fact i've had
many of my students that are university
students
and i mean there's one guy john raybould
he was at sheffield university
he was building a portfolio of hmos with
joint ventures and stuff like that
he left uni recently never asked to have
a job in his life because he's got a
portfolio of properties
so you can do this while at uni you can
do property investment alongside a job
alongside a
any profession alongside a business
alongside university so yes
you can get started um
miles some phone can you outline all the
costs needed to set up a property
business
eg insurances so a lot of costs
like insurances you're not going to have
to pay right away
you're not going to have to pay until
you own the house but when you own the
house
you're going to get rent so you can pay
a lot of management
maintenance insurance you don't pay for
that stuff
your tenant pays for that stuff when
your tenant pays you rent
you put a percentage of the rent aside
for insurance
management maintenance etc so
the costs of setting up the business
wouldn't include things like insurances
really depends on what the business is
um i mean it depends on what the
property business is
entirely is it a deal sourcing business
if it is
again focus on the money early on
because you can very easily spend money
on graphic design
websites business cards company setup
uh freaking consultants to
help you get the best logo it doesn't
matter
what matters is your ability to make
money and you don't need money to make
money that's one of the biggest myths
ever
you if you want to do deal sourcing you
might go oh but i need to have a company
i need to be compliant no you don't
just package a deal pass it to a co to a
code your source let them sell it for
you
and you just get a quick commission fee
get
paid focus on money making activities
and then you can use that money to
slowly build your business
last question mr s can you explain the
exact steps
and due diligence you do to find a
suitable property for rent to
rent how do you know there won't be any
problems in the future how can you make
sure the property will attract tenants
okay mr s really good question so
depending on if it's a rent to rent hmo
or rent to rent service accommodation
um the due diligence you're going to
take into account is what's the supply
and demand in the area
if it's a hmo what is
what are the current rooms for rent
who's looking for a room go on
spareroom.com and look at
flatmates people looking for rooms or
rooms wanted scroll through look at how
much they're prepared to pay
phone them up have a chat speak to some
hmo management companies if it's
serviced accommodation
go on air dna go on airbnb
and look at other people's calendars and
see how full they are and how much
they're renting them out for
go to some hotels in the area and say
have you got any we're looking for a
uh six of my colleagues to rent some
accommodation from this hotel tonight
and if they go yeah no problem you might
think well there's a lot of empty rooms
if they're like oh my goodness you're
having a laugh we're fully booked for
the next two weeks
so do due diligence but most importantly
always have a break
clause in your rent to rent contracts
meaning if it doesn't work out as you
hoped
you can hand the keys back and walk away
so i hope that's helpful
looking forward to hearing more of your
property investment questions comment
them in the chat box or in the comment
box i should say
and i'll do my very best to answer your
questions next week if you appreciate
me putting time aside to do a video
every single day
then please help me out by smashing the
like button because that will
help more people see the videos
and ultimately means more people get
educated and leave their jobs become
financially free which is what my
mission is for sure so smash the like
button
subscribe and i'll see you guys next
time you